So in this problem, we start out with n
number of people with big heads and happy smiles.
And after every hexamester, each one of
our happy udacians goes out and asks
spread number of their friends
to also take the course.
This process continues as long as the
number of udacians is less than the target.
With a little bit of math, you can solve
this pretty straightforward,
and you might have done it in
middle school or high school,
but we're going to use recursion
to solve this problem very easily.
Remember what we're looking for is the
number of hexamesters this process goes through
until we reach the target.
I saw on the forms a couple of people
were trying to use global variables
that counted recursive calls,
but really that kind of defeats the purpose in
the power that we can use in the recursion.
I'm going to show you how to do that right now.
So our base case says that if we've met our
target, then we don't need any time to spread
in order to reach the target because
we're already there.
Now here I have a + 1 because we're
going to say that we're doing 1 iteration
of the udacian spreading process.
Now for the recursive call.
The first thing we need is n.
Well, n is going to be the same thing as last
time + how many new people we've gotten,
which is spread x n.
A more succinct way of writing this would
be simply n x (1 + spread).
The spreading rate doesn't change,
so we're going to leave that alone.
Our target doesn't change.
And that's it. We're done.